est ce que vous étiez bon français un
mauvais but au bacon français pour ceux
qui ont passé le bac ou bien sûr ce sera
le certificat des trois nuls vous avez
couvert la note au graff une cata et
aura au niveau des eaux au niveau rural
au raf une cascade licata et français
j'ai eu cette croix donc vous êtes un
mauvais à l'écrit move alors alloué
mauvais les clubs alors oui non c'est en
français cette emprise à vous êtes vous
avez pu le prendre culture benjamin
ouais mais oui mais le français sur nuke
benhaim à café oendan époque année il
faut pas tabac 12 à l'écrit 17 à l'oral
quoi nous a dit voilà la dure brouillé
l'organisait à l'examinateur alors
alouettes 7
elle est belle je me souviens plus des 9
pc des bonnes notes je suis imbattable
en orthographe
c'est après par oui vraiment mais bon je
vais tester ça non non vous moi j'ai
arrêté l'école à 15 ans donc je suis une
bonne en orthographe
mais depuis que je suis à rendre des
gens des fois que des importants grâce à
vous des fachos j'envoie des mails
faudra répondre tellement peur que même
le correcteur il ne donne pas le mot en
fait je voulais sur google pour aller
voir commence à s'écrire et après envoyé
mon texto je m'attends pas possible chez
moi c'est la même école d'acteurs bien
merci en tout cas elle ne pas prendre de
risques
oui j'ai perdait 7 avec ready set à
l'oral à la coupe bien ou mytho c'est
vrai 17 à l'équipe nationale aura une
espèce de mythe ôta u17 au bac avec 18
l'influencé était ici et 18 en philo et
18 en finale
les frères falic courante les affaires
barre 17 17
parce que j'ai eus j'avais eu trois ans
match j'avais arrêté les maths en fait
une femme excédée sur m6
on croit vous avez ou kenza l'écrit 16 à
l'oral c'est en philo c'est un lapin
c'est en latin n'aura pas la faisait des
dictats nuss alors j'ai passé un bac b
sciences économiques sociales à l'époque
en dise et b14 allait créer 12 à l'oral
non oui mais il est bon simon tient non
j'étais meilleur en philo g 16 en philo
ce mois tu crois que tu vas me faire
tout à collomb est en bac 8
ouais franchement je me rappelle pas du
tout parce que je détestais le français
allez je me rappelle pas de mignotte
d'accord c'est ni le français ni
histoire gmail et matt que les matelas
fils leur match et c'est pas une bonne
note mais honnêtement je redescends tes
deux minutes 8
doc gynéco moi je suis très nul nul j'ai
créé en sténo fois j'écris en sténo des
hiéroglyphes je fais pas donné sa très
belle envoyée
essayez de savoir ce qu'il a voulu dire
il a dit j'ai des hiéroglyphes sténo oui
oui j'ai l'écriture pas possible
impossible vraiment si vous avez passé
le bac même pas non mais pas passer le
bac
non non j'ai arrêté l'école moi aussi
mais plus tard plus tard quand même un
peu tard que le bac avant mais vous
savez non non non non mais vous êtes et
c'est quoi un troisième est votre cursus
ariane particulier j'aime beaucoup
traîné dehors
d'accord mais au niveau de l'est des
études et brûlées selon quelle classe je
sais vérité au collège
oui au collège louis le nos collègues
ces sectes jusqu'à troisième à laon
ouais c'est ça et après la seconde ça
vous dit quelque chose
non on vous dit alors oui j'ai passé la
première j'ai pas fait tout ça d'études
c'est beaucoup c'est vrai c'est avec ces
découvertes va pas revenir au temps
passé merci bien je vais vous dire la
vérité il écrivait s'est vu et je le dis
et si c'est pas une balle j'ai eu 12 à
l'écrit fait bien et j'ai eu 13 à l'oral
non on va vérifier non non je vous le
dis bonjour vous êtes tombé sur vous
souvenez du texte que vous avez sur les
lettres personnes montesquieu trop
j'embrasse d'ailleurs mangé avec lui
hier soir il ya beaucoup de fourchette